here for the audience that is not trying
to understand why in 2019 are we seeing
a foolish that was originally shot in
1970 well everybody can now see you know
there's there's two people that I think
I can feel their spirit today and I know
they would love to be here and in the
last shot of the movie you get to see
Aretha Franklin and Sydney [ __ ] and
um and you can you know Aretha would
like to be near those two and Sydney did
too you know so there was that energy
Sydney had a bad day bad two days he
didn't bring a clapper and you can see
all of those cameramen running around
and they're not like modern-day
cameramen where they're you know they're
dressed in black and they're trying
their I mean they're wearing like nudie
suits and rhinestones and and like but
the one thing you don't see in the whole
movie is somebody walking around with
one of those so Sydney who had never Doc
made a documentary before in the in the
months that we work together before he
got sick and passed away he never talked
about it because I think he was really
embarrassed about it and and and I just
wanted to see the movie and he was like
well you know there's some stuff and we
should do this and we should do that and
I was like whoa and and when he passed
Alexander Hamilton came up because they
delivered a bunch of boxes to my house
and there was film and Sydney had said
there was interviews and there's a work
print and there's all this stuff and I
was like okay great this will be an easy
way to get into the movie business let's
get out of the record business we'll go
right into the movie business
somebody easy there's a Sydney [ __ ]
movie sitting there no there's not so
they get these boxes and then I go
through a dossier and all of a sudden I
see we've hired Alexander Hamilton as a
lip-reader
and then I knew we had a problem and so
that began you know this
a you know Homeric journey home home
literally I mean like I'm in Beverly
Hills I grew up here so I'm like
literally home could you specify what
type of film elements you had to work
with if you ever pulled from this 16
millimeter film 2 inch tape and Nagre
film and you know you could also see
that guys I mean they're they're running
around they're taking pictures and
they're turning the cameras on they're
turning them off turning them on turning
them off turning them on turning off and
bill stein camp who Alex I called Alex
before I called bill Stein camp and I
introduced myself and Alex said yeah we
could never get the film sunk together
so then Donna Ostroff who was Sydney's
assistant introduced me to Bill Stein
camp who was Sydney's editor and Bill's
father Fritz was Sydney's editor before
bill and bill was 17 years old and I
called him and he started laughing and
he's like oh we had 2,000 pieces of film
and we had no idea where to sink them to
and so they worked with Alex for a
couple months and they just gave up and
the saddest part of like this incredible
journey of the movie coming out and all
this sort of stuff was we went to do the
Palm Springs Film Festival and Donna
Ostroff Sidney's assistant was there and
Donna in you know because we're in an
industry room everybody you know you're
in Hollywood right so you're on the
phone with Sydney [ __ ] but you're
really on the phone with Sydney [ __ ]
and Donna Ostroff and Donna was on the
phone for every one of the conversations
and Donna said to me when we went to
play Palm Springs she said I never told
you this but and as I go it's gonna be
one of those because I've gotten a lot
of those but and her butt was between
projects Sydney would ask Warner
Brothers to send the film over and we
would watch it in the dark with no sound
and I was like that's really sad and
really moving I mean cuz you know he
knew it he just couldn't get there and
you accidentally called me director I'm
not the family wasn't comfortable with
me taking that and I didn't want it and
I'd wanted it you know I defer to you
create this realization that became yeah
whatever
yeah I figured well my father spent some
time in France we figured realization
would be a better word for but are you
aware of the depth yeah I deserve that
one yeah yes because I've been pondering
over that to be ready for this Q&A it's
not an accident so um I would like you I
heard someplace that you said that you
chose the editing structure of a
Broadway show yes I explained that uh
well I've told this story so he's and
he's not here tonight so I can tell it
again like every movie I think anybody's
ever made you make the first cut and you
think it's the greatest movie in the
world and it was three hours long and
there were about four people at the
movie theater or William Morris I made a
screening and I thought I had made the
greatest movie ever and Alex was there
and Rick Rubin was there and and um
Phil Jackson the basketball coach was
there and Phil Jackson had just had
prostate cancer surgery which I didn't
know until we walked into the theater
and he said to me I just had prostate
cancer surgery and then I realized we
had to start making some editing choices
very quickly because I wanted my friend
out of there as fast as we could get and
on the way home I grew up in Broadway
musicals and I said we're gonna steal
the structure of Broadway musicals which
is if anybody knows basically also goes
back to Shakespeare you start the movie
with you know the choir and this is the
choir and this is a wreath of Franklin
and this is Jerry Wexler and this is
Sydney [ __ ] and there's the
soundboard and this is all of these
pieces that are going to come there and
then you get into the first song which
is the walk in and the walk in is sort
of you know
comedy tonight you know it's something
exciting something invite something for
everyone a comedy tonight which is we
are on our way and that explains why
we're here
the next song is what they call an I
wish song which is holy holy you know
that all men could live as brothers then
you get into an up-tempo number you sort
of crest with a big end of the first
night which is amazing grace you don't
know that oh my God he's gonna go where
are we gonna go after Amazing Grace and
it is there also before a mercy in grace
that James Cleveland become becomes very
melancholic yes starts remembering back
into the days
yes Arisa and it also sets the tempo for
the second chapter absolutely and then
you know the structure the structure of
Broadway musicals is just what Jeff
Buchanan who edited the movie and I I
sort of taught him about Broadway
musicals which he knew inherently so
Aretha died less than a year ago
doublelift yeah and regardless of her
reasons not to want the film to be seen
it is obvious that this is a beautiful
tribute to the relationship of a father
and a daughter if our ISA were here with
you today
what would you be your appeal to her
your last appeal to Aretha you know the
time thing reveals these things that you
don't see like one of the Mary Hall my
good friend over there Mary and I talked
about this like every time we watch the
movie because we'd had to watch the
movie a lot of times you see something
different because there's all these long
takes and you'll see a guy in the back
or you'll see somebody and at the time
when I got the movie I thought well this
will be something she would love what I
didn't understand at the time was Warner
Brothers had promised her she was going
to be a movie star and that year Diana
Ross got to make you know Lady Sings the
Blues and that year Barbra Streisand
right after this got to make the way we
were and aretha want to be a movie star
and I didn't take that into account ten
years ago because I just want to get a
Moo
be made because I knew this record I
knew how important the record was and
then you know we went to Telluride Film
Festival because Warner Brothers you
know in there's no shortage of crazy
that went on in this movie you know
Warner Brothers films and records were
one company at the time by the time I
get it
the record company has been sold off and
nobody wants to deal with Aretha
Franklin the film company doesn't want
to deal with her
the record company doesn't want to deal
with her and nobody wants to show me her
contract and then like four years ago
five years ago Steve Spiros they had a
business affairs at Warner Brothers said
we found it and I was like oh well what
can I do now and he's like you can go
make the removi so of course I call Ruth
the Franklin's 15 lawyers and 23 agents
and say hey we found this contract what
do you want to do and they don't know
because they can't get an answer and I
never met her I met her once for five
seconds in 2008 so they say well you
should go and make the movie and pay her
okay but what we didn't know at the time
after she showed up or you know she
showed up at this court hearing in
Denver was that she had pancreatic
cancer and her niece who's a very good
friend and as a producer on the movie
Sabrina Owens called me after we had
lost in Telluride and she said I don't
have to tell you something but you can't
say anything okay um she said you know
Rita's got pancreatic cancer she's had
it for five years
and I was like oh well then we can't put
the movie yet and she so we came up with
this thing which is we would check in
with each other every couple of months
and I would say we have to make an
insurance payment and you know and and
we became friendly and but you know I
didn't start the movie to make to poke a
hole and you know poke a finger in the
eye of Aretha Franklin it was to make
giant love letter to her and sink Adam
for you thank you all for coming